Welcome to the deep dive where
we really try to get under the
surface of things.
So let me ask you, have you ever
felt that little flicker, maybe
that almost uncomfortable
feeling when you think about
societal support systems, like a
kind of resentment you can't
quite put your finger on that
little twitch.
What if, and here's the thing,
what if that feeling is like,
way older than any government
program?
Really, really old.
Rooted in something, I don't
know, primal.
That's exactly the territory,
yeah.
Fascinating and honestly pretty
uncomfortable ground we're
covering today because this deep
dive, it's it's not really about
the policy details, your
budgets, regulations, that
stuff.
We're going deeper.
We're digging into the the human
side, the moral feelings that
sometimes unsettling stuff
around giving and receiving
help.
And the source we're using
today, it offers this really
surprising way of looking at it
all challenges, some big
assumptions.
Right.
And that source is a piece by
Chris Abraham called America's
Welfare Fatigue, the Moral
Economy of the Met.
And, you know, he kicks it off
with this very self aware
description, calls himself just
a 53 year old cisgender white
male, mansplaining his own self
importance, but good.
Which, you know, sets a certain
tone.
But we're not really focused on
that part.
We're using his diagnosis, his
insights to unpack what he calls
this secret psychic cost, you
know, the hidden emotional toll
maybe at the heart of our safety
Nets.
So our mission really is to
figure out why this welfare
fatigue feels so, well, real to
so many people, even if we don't
talk about it much, and what
that tells us about, you know,
us humans.
Exactly.
And that the source really
pushes this idea that beneath
all the good intentions, all the
modern systems, there's this
ancient tension.
It's not just economics, not
just politics.
It goes way back.
It's psychological.
So yeah, we're peeling back the
layers today, trying to
understand the why behind the
fatigue, not just the complaints
about fraud or whatever, but the
the deeper almost gut feelings
involved.
It might be a little bit
uncomfortable looking in that
mirror, but definitely
illuminating.
OK, let's unpack this
foundational idea.
Then the source hits US right
away with this core argument.
Every modern welfare system
contains the seeds of its own
discontent.
Now that sounds strong because
on the surface, these systems,
they seem noble, right?
Compassionate.
The idea is simple.
We share the load.
We look after the vulnerable
pool resources, make sure nobody
falls through the cracks.
Sounds good.
Sounds great, Yeah, Who wouldn't
want that?
But Abraham says there's a but a
big one right from the start.
A kind of haunting tension.
And that but is where he brings
in this haunting tension, as he
calls it something older than
any bureaucracy.
He talks about this uneasy human
craving for visible
helplessness, which is wow,
think about that.
We want to be generous, right?
We want to give freely.
But then deep down, maybe
unconsciously, we feel this.
This resentment if the person
getting help doesn't seem broken
enough.
Broken enough?
Yeah, or grateful enough.
Or small enough.
That's the phrasing he uses.
And he's saying this isn't just
about modern taxes and forms.
This is ancient, primal.
Like you said.
It's like giving for the giver
comes with this unspoken
expectation of seeing a certain
kind of performance from the
receiver.
Performance of need.
Exactly.
We want to help, but we also
want to see the need to see the
gratitude, often in a way that
frankly reinforces the power
dynamic.
What do you mean about the
giver's moral comfort too?
Which leads right into this idea
of welfare fatigue being the
secret psychic cost, the cost no
budget line ever itemizes but
that everyone senses.
I love that line.
It's that feeling, right?
Yeah.
That maybe you felt or you've
seen it in others when the
person receiving aid, maybe they
might stand up straight when
they should stay crouched and
scraping.
That's another powerful image he
uses.
It really is.
It's not about the money, is it?
It's deeper, like feeling
morally, I don't know, ripped
off, even if there's no actual
fraud.
Yeah, or like the unspoken rules
were broken.
This psychic cost really gets
it.
Something uncomfortable about
us, about human nature, what we
expect when we offer charity.
We want to feel good about
giving inherently, but a lot of
that good feeling, that moral
comfort, seems to come from
seeing a certain level of, well,
humility, maybe even objection,
honestly.
And when that's disrupted, when
the person helped doesn't fit
our old fashioned picture of the
deserving poor.
Then the resentment kicks in,
The fatigue.
Exactly.
And it's not rational, not about
efficiency.
It's emotional, deeply human.
As the source keep saying.
The giver is looking for
validation, maybe for their own
goodness.
And if the receiver looks too.
Whole Too independent, yeah.
Then that validation doesn't
quite land.
The transaction feels off,
incomplete, leaves you feeling
uneasy, like your visible need
validates my generosity.
If that's missing, the whole
thing feels shaky.
This idea of performance, it's
absolutely key here.
Which brings us to that really
vivid story he tells about the
ancient beggar.
Can you picture it?
This beggar in some old village,
He gets this whole dynamic
instinctively.
He's not just asking for scraps.
He's putting on a show, a
performance of need.
He made himself legless, or at
least appeared so crawling on a
pallet, tapping his bowl,
keeping his eyes down, never
making eye contact.
And the source says this wasn't
new.
This performance was as old as
bread.
It was a ritual designed to get
a specific reaction.
Unnecessary reaction.
Yeah, a whole social dance
really, based on these perceived
moral duties.
And that performance, it's built
on this unspoken social
contract, a moral economy,
right?
The beggar knew, Abraham says.
The value of the costume knew
the difference between the
ruined coat for the square and
the cleaner tunic for home.
OK, So what we might call fraud
today.
Right, he reframes it.
It wasn't fraud in that context.
It was part of the deal.
Visible Rowan in exchange for
alms, Secrecy for small
dignities carried behind closed
doors.
The beggar knew implicitly that
the village would keep seating
him only so long as he gave them
back their moral comfort.
Their moral comfort, That's the
key.
Absolutely.
This wasn't some abstract
government program.
It was face to face, local,
personal.
If the performance failed, if
the villagers lost patience,
there was no safety net, you
crawled to the next town or you
starved.
So that directness, that
visceral link between the
performance and survival, it
really shows how deep these
expectations run.
The villagers needed to feel
compassionate and the beggar
provided the proof.
OK, but here's where it gets
really interesting, right?
Because he takes that ancient
scene and slams it right into
our modern world.
He says.
The problem is not that the
moral instinct has changed, but
that we pretend it has while
building a machinery that
depends on the old moral reflex.
So we say we want empowerment,
dignity.
We talk about helping people get
back on their feet, become
whole, independent.
We tell ourselves these nice
stories, maybe invoke religious
ideals like the loaves and
fishes as if Jesus was running a
state funded food bank.
Right.
We have these high ideals we
talk about, but what?
Happens when the reality doesn't
match that subconscious ancient
script, when our gut reaction
clashes with our stated values.
That's exactly it.
That's when is the source puts
it so uncomfortably.
The suspicion of betrayal blooms
like mildew in the soul.
It happens when the recipients
just don't look or act the way
our deep seated expectations say
they should.
Not sufficiently grateful or
perpetually pitiful.
And he gives those modern
examples.
Yeah, they're really concrete
ones that probably make people
nod even if they don't want to
admit it.
Posting a selfie with a new
phone, standing up too straight
in the queue, wearing decent
shoes, speaking too freely about
what they feel they're owed.
Things that break the image of
helplessness.
Exactly, and the point he
hammers Hone is this reaction,
this suspicion, is not rational,
but it is deeply human.
It's not always about actual
provable fraud, though, that's a
separate issue.
This is more about the optics,
the optics of undeserving, the
visual cues that just violate
that unwritten contract.
The welfare office itself might
not demand you limp, but the
public mind, the collective
feeling, it often does.
That fragile membrane, he calls
it, between giver and receiver.
It needs that visible difference
between the humbled recipient
and the standing resentful
giver.
Why?
Why does it need that
difference?
Because, he argues, that
difference is what keeps the
whole moral economy flowing.
It keeps the givers feeling OK
about giving.
The state system might be
managing social unrest risk, but
this performance manages the
risk of moral revolt from the
people paying for it.
That fatigue.
It's subtle, emotional, not
logical.
Deeply emotional.
We want to give, but maybe
unconsciously we demand
something back.
A visible performance of need.
This is, yeah, it is definitely
forcing a look in the mirror,
But the source doesn't just
leave us there.
It offers this really disruptive
alternative Jesus's approach to
giving, which he describes as
coming in with a sledgehammer
and also with a crust of bread.
Right, a total disruption.
And the key distinction Right
off the bat?
Jesus fed thousands, yes, but
never with Caesar's taxes.
That's fundamental, absolutely
critical.
It sets it completely apart from
our modern state-run systems, a
different kind of economy
altogether.
How so?
What was the difference?
Well, the source points out, he
multiplied fish and loaves not
by commanding the local treasury
to fund it, but by taking what
was freely offered.
Remember just a few scraps from
a boy handed back out with
nothing asked in return except
faith.
Except faith, not paperwork.
Exactly.
And the principle was clear.
You received without charge,
give without charge.
That's from Matthew.
He wasn't setting up permanent
dole collectors or sending
invoices to the Roman
government.
When he sent his disciples out,
he told them essentially rely on
the hospitality of those who
help.
The Labor deserves his keep.
So not endless handouts.
No, it was more like a direct
short circuit exchange.
Give what you have, receive what
you need, move on if they do not
want it.
And that move on part is key.
That's the mercy with edges.
Mercy with edges.
I like that.
What does it mean practically?
It means there were
consequences.
Boundaries.
Remember the instruction.
If anyone will not welcome you
or listen to your words, shake
the dust off your feet when you
leave that home or town.
Yeah, the source calls it mercy
that gave freely but never
begged to be received, mercy
that walked away the moment it
became a farce.
It's a stark contrast to modern
systems that often feel like
they're constantly justifying
their existence, begging to be
accepted by both taxpayers and
recipients.
This was different.
It implied a certain
responsibility even in receiving
help.
And related to that, this
powerful idea that Jesus refused
to keep the healed man on the
mat, but that that symbol of
brokenness, dependency, right
the place of the helpless.
But Jesus's instruction again
and again was get up, take your
mat and walk.
Right and often.
Go show yourself to the priest,
meaning meaning reintegrate, go
back into the community, resume
your life, prove your healing
within the existing social
structure.
He wasn't just fixing bodies, he
was pushing them back towards
self efficiency, immediately
disrupting that performance of
helplessness.
So the source argues, there was
no third option.
Pretty much you either rejoin
the community or you stayed
broken.
You didn't get to just crawl
back to the mat for tomorrow's
scraps.
No perpetual dependency built
into the miracle itself.
Which is uncomfortable when you
think about our modern debates
about gratitude, long term aid.
Very uncomfortable and the
source leans into it.
He points out where Jesus did
not do many mighty works there
because of their unbelief,
Meaning if people weren't
receptive, if they mocked the
help or were ungrateful, he
didn't keep pushing.
He did not reach deeper into
Jesus's purse to keep the
ungrateful alive.
Judas's purse, meaning the
collective resources they had.
Exactly, He didn't force the
help, he shook the dust and
moved on.
Which leads to that provocative
label the source uses.
Asshole.
Jesus.
Whoa.
OK, deliberately jarring the
point is about aside.
We sanitize the man who fed you
without asking your tax status,
but who would not feed you twice
if you mocked the miracle.
It's not about cruelty.
It's about a mercy focused on
transformation and
responsibility, not just endless
feeding.
So it raises that really tough
question, what is true mercy?
Is it always just endless
provision no matter what?
Does it have a goal beyond just
keeping someone alive, Like
restoring dignity?
Yeah, agency.
That seems to be the
implication.
And that clarity, those edges,
they really highlight the modern
system's dilemma, don't they?
The source says.
Our system wants to be
infinitely merciful with someone
else's money.
It wants transformation without
offense, pity without limits.
Yeah, it's trying to square an
impossible circle.
Universal compassion funded by
taxes without any of the hard
edges or personal challenges.
And that's where the critique
gets really sharp, that moral
contradiction.
Abraham says the modern system
wants the Kingdom of Heaven
funded by Caesar's purse and
empire's bread lines with the
moral glow of the loaves and
fishes trying to get the warm
fuzzy feeling of personal
charity from an impersonal
compulsory system.
And when it doesn't work?
When the fatigue sets in.
Then the blame game starts.
Blame the recipient for being
proud.
Blame the taxpayer for being
stingy.
Blame the politicians.
But, the source argues, never
blame the core contradiction.
Trying to graft a personal
voluntary ethic onto an
impersonal mandatory system and
expecting the same results, the
same feelings, it just breeds
resentment.
OK, so let's get practical then.
Beyond the ideals, what does the
source say the modern system
actually does, if not miracles?
He calls it the de facto company
store for the moral class.
That's the strong image.
It is very provocative, the
company store analogy, you know,
it suggests system that traps
people, keeps in the dependent
rather than freeing them.
Well, historically, company
stores kept workers in debt to
the employer.
Abraham uses it to suggest the
welfare system has a different,
maybe more cynical, function
than just helping people.
It's real job, he argues, is to
keep the masses pacify, prevent
riots, keep the desperate from
becoming too desperate, and
crucially, to reassure the
middle that they are not
monsters for letting so many
slip through the cracks.
It manages guilt.
So it's more about maintenance
than transformation.
That's the argument, since real
transformation is not built in,
because it's about managing the
problem, not solving it.
Then the scraping ever ends.
It's managing symptoms, keeping
things stable, preserving the
moral self-image of the
comfortable, maybe more than
truly empowering the vulnerable.
Which leads to what he calls the
quiet mutual fraud.
Explain that.
OK, so if the system is this
company store managing
perceptions and keeping things
quiet, then the practical result
is Harsh.
The beggar who forgets the
script jeopardizes the teat for
everyone.
Meaning if you don't perform the
expected helplessness.
Right.
If the performance of ruin is
not maintained, if you stand up
too straight, look too healthy,
seem to okay, then the whole
system comes under scrutiny.
People start demanding audits,
more rules cuts that welfare
fatigue flares up.
The message is play the part
where the support dries up for
everyone.
So the poor learn.
They learned to lean into the
visible ruin, to crawl
convincingly, to keep the Chanel
tunic hidden at home.
That's the quiet mutual fraud.
It's this unspoken deal.
The taxpayer, consciously or
not, wants the theater.
They need to see the struggle to
feel OK about the giving.
And the recipient.
The recipient delivers it, they
perform the expected role, and
the breast keeps producing milk.
So long as the performance
reassures the moral mind that no
one is getting away with
anything, the show has to go on.
Think about those viral moments,
right?
Someone on benefits caught doing
something that looks too good.
Exactly.
The outrage isn't just about the
money.
It's about breaking the script,
shattering the illusion that
keeps the system palatable.
It's a performance for survival.
How does this play out now in
our world of smartphones and
social media?
The source brings in this modern
twist.
The beggar has a phone, a
camera, an audience way bigger
than the village square.
The ancient rolling pallet has a
live feed.
Yeah, and that visibility
changes everything.
The Internet has made the old
double life harder to contain.
That line he talks about between
survival, performance and real
healing, it gets incredibly
blurry when everything's
potentially public.
So someone performs need during
the day, but then posts a
picture at night.
Exactly.
Celebrating something small,
maybe just living, not realizing
who's watching.
And those moments get
screenshotted, clipped, remixed.
The hidden Chanel, the decent
meal, the joke about scamming
the system taken out of context,
spread everywhere.
And the result is.
Predictable outrage cries of
fraud.
Not because, as the source says,
the con is new, but because the
illusion cracked in public.
It shows how fragile that whole
moral comfort thing is when you
can't control the performance
anymore, when the backstage
becomes visible.
The Internet just rips the
curtain down, constantly
threatening to expose how this
moral economy actually works.
And that just fuels more
fatigue, more suspicion.
So the take away seems to be if
you want the milk to keep
flowing, you must keep the
performance tight.
The source is blunt about what's
required.
The ruin must be visible, The
scraping must be audible.
The mat must stay in view.
The grateful thank you, Sir,
must always be ready.
It's incredibly bleak, isn't it?
Almost demeaning?
It essentially locks people into
performing victimhood.
And the darker side of that.
Is the warning never stand up
too straight unless you are
ready to stand fully on your own
and register yourself with the
priests.
The system as he sees it has no
patience for healed people who
keep asking for the scraps.
It's either visibly broken or
totally independent.
That's the implication.
No comfortable middle ground,
because if someone looks too
whole while still getting help,
the village will feel cheated.
And then everyone pays.
The contract is broken,
resentment flares.
The whole system feels
threatened.
It reinforces the idea that it's
about managing a visible
problem, not fostering gradual
independence.
Which loops back to his core
diagnosis, the real moral
disease.
It's not, he says, that some
people fake need.
That happens, sure, but it's not
the root problem, no.
The true disease, he argues, is
that the system quietly demands
they perform it perpetually.
Wow, so the problem isn't the
individual faking it, but the
system requiring the
performance.
That's the shift in perspective.
It incentivizes staying in that
visibly helpless role.
Yeah, the healed must always
carry a mat.
Just in case he writes this
endless ritual.
Show yourself to the priest.
Show yourself to the caseworker.
Show yourself to the taxpayer.
Constant move of need.
Yeah, and that constant need to
prove you're still broke and
still deserving.
It actually works against
genuine self-sufficiency.
It traps people.
The disease isn't the faking.
It's the system's demand for a
performance that prevents real
healing and autonomy.
It keeps both sides stuck in
this resentful dance.
And then the postscript.
It gets even more provocative.
Alms have always been the
blackmail price for calling
yourself civilized.
They are not love.
They are not healing.
They are the hush money paid to
keep the ruin out of sight that
really challenges everything we
think about charity.
It does.
It recasts welfare completely,
not as compassion but as a
performance, more than a policy,
like moral landscaping that
keeps the mansion looking neat
while the servant quarters
crumble behind the hedge.
And he compares it to.
To a big man in a poor country,
feeding the people in his
courtyard, Not out of pure
kindness, maybe, but if only to
silence the gossip that he is no
better than the rest.
It's reputation management.
So applying that to us, things
like food banks, housing
vouchers.
He argues cities tolerate these
things not because they believe
in healing or wholeness, but
because it would be too
shameful, too bad for the family
name to see the cousins starving
out on the front steps.
Hush money basically paid to
maintain the illusion of
functioning, caring first world
society to manage the guilt and
discomfort of the well off
keeping up appearances.
So this whole fragile system,
this unspoken deal, it only
holds as long as everyone stays
in their assigned role.
Pretty much.
The poor stay visibly pitiful.
The comfortable keep the aid
flowing just enough to keep
things quiet, keep the front
yard looking OK, maintain their
own moral comfort.
It's a really delicate, maybe
even resentful, balance.
And if that balance tips, if the
scraping stops, if the beggars
look too whole, If they forget
how to crawl on the mat, the
contract stamps the final,
uncomfortable conclusion we feed
them not to lift them, but to
keep the ruin politely hidden.
It's cynical, maybe, but the
source argues it might be a more
realistic look at how much of
our societal support actually
functions underneath the
surface.
Managing perception, maintaining
order, soothing guilt more than
genuine transformation.
Wow, OK, we have definitely
taken a deep dive there into
welfare fatigue and this
underlying tension between
wanting to help and needing to
see helplessness.
We've traced it from ancient
villages with beggars performing
their need.
Right, that performance for
alms.
All the way to today's social
media feeds where those
performances are constantly
under scrutiny, often falling
apart in public view.
And we contrasted that with the
sources take on Jesus's mercy
with edges, voluntary giving,
pushing for self-sufficiency,
clear boundaries.
Compared to the modern system
trying for infinite mercy with
someone else's money, which kind
of traps people in that
performance of ruin.
Yeah, that struggle to reconcile
ideals with these deep, often
conflicting human feelings.
So the source leaves us with
some really tough questions to
chew on, doesn't it?
He says the cure for this
fatigue isn't going to come from
shaming recipients for wanting
to stand up or shaming taxpayers
for wanting proof if their help
isn't being mocked.
Right, those are just symptoms.
The real cure, he suggests,
comes from asking a much harder,
older question. 1 The Gospels
apparently ask directly.
Which is.
What is mercy for if not to help
a man stand?
And what do we do, What do we
owe, when he will not?
That it's hard.
It's not just theological, is
it?
It's about how we design
support, what we value is
dignity, and where the limits of
generosity lie.
Maybe.
Definitely something to think
about, how these ancient
patterns, these unspoken deals,
might still be playing out all
around us, shaping how we see
and respond to need.
Absolutely.
A lot to reflect on there.